megyn kelly is clapping back at Jane
Fonda honestly she has no business
lecturing anyone on what qualifies as
offensive here's the back story
controversy first erupted between the
news anchor and the actress in September
when Jane was a guest on megyn kelly
today to promote her film our souls at
night and didn't appreciate this
question I read that you said you felt
you're not proud to admit you've had
work done why not we really want to talk
about Jane has since publicly thrown
shade at Megan a few times recently
calling her quote not that good an
interviewer and on Monday Megan was
ready to respond
she has discussed her cosmetic-surgery
pretty much everywhere before coming on
our show I have no regrets about that
question nor am I in the market for a
lesson from Jane Fonda on what is and is
not appropriate Megan also called out
Jane's controversial past she posed on
an anti-aircraft gun used to shoot down
our American pilots she called our POWs
hypocrites and liars and referred to
their torture as understandable the
Grace and Frankie star recently turned
80 in September she told the tea her
secret to living well it's not a
lifestyle it's a life I I lead a healthy
life I try to to hang with people who
have good attitudes and because you know
who you spend time with matters to ya
and try to move towards the light rather
than then move towards the darkness
[Music]
you